a well-known baby food manufacturer
announced a major recall just this past
week on several baby formula brands this
after several infants became sick with
bacterial infections and tonight we hear
from another family whose son is
currently fighting for his life
madison kimbrell live in the newsroom
with their story madison yeah this is
the second family to reach out to us in
regards to their infant being
hospitalized after consuming abbott
nutrition formula and the side effects
these babies are going through are
startling
i just checked his temperature and
davian's temperature is 104 and then
he's moaning and groaning he's red like
pepper red another family in the valley
distraught over their infant's condition
as a recall of abbott nutrition baby
formula is causing newborns to become
severely ill two-month-old baby davian
jones is currently at sunrise hospital's
icu suffering from severe dehydration
and thrush with bowel issues and he
can't keep down any of his formula his
grandmother melon co says they are
running out of food supply options for
him it has me scared because he when he
gets released of course they're going to
release him with some other kind of
formula who's to say this formula is not
going to kill us something or have a
recall i mean hearing that there's moms
out here that's making breast milk for
these kids because of this situation
pharmacist dr christina madison says
that while there is a baby formula
shortage right now with the addition of
this recall it's eye opening to see how
many formulas are made by the same
manufacturer that's not giving many
options for parents and their newborns
if a particular brand like abbott
nutrition doesn't work out when you go
to the store
you have a brand name and then you have
a generic name so it's the same thing
with baby formula where maybe it's one
manufacturer but then they have several
different products that they make you
think that you're buying um a different
product but really you're just buying
the same product under a different name
now a formula isn't working for your
child and you're unable to provide them
with your own breast milk there are
donor banks available where you can go
and buy milk as for davian's condition
he will remain in the icu at sunrise
hospital until he is strong enough to be
at home on his own reporting live in the
newsroom madison kimbrough live local
now